the raiders play their last game
sunday as the regular nfl season comes
to a close and
ron futrell is talking to the betting
experts to see
which teams could be heading to the
super bowl this year
so here we go final weekend of the nfl's
regular season week 17 if you will
a good opportunity here to take a look
at who are the favorites to make it to
the super bowl this year
so we go to the experts at bet mgm the
kansas city is the top team in the
afc they're eight to five to uh for the
super bowl green bay is the uh leader in
the nfc they're at six to one
follow closely behind the saints at
seven to one and uh in the
buffalo is nine to one seattle tampa bay
are both 10 to 1.
now the raiders close out the season
sunday at denver
earlier this season the raiders smacked
the broncos 37-12
in a game where their defense forced
five turnovers
we opened that game at one and a half
and money has come in at the raiders and
they're up to two and a half now
uh there were some places that opened
that game uh up uh
uh the night earlier and the broncos
were actually a two point favorite so
it's flipped to uh the raiders now so
money coming in on the raiders
so the raiders wrapping up the season in
chile denver against the broncos
raiders hoping to finish the season with
an eight and eight record
which would mean at least they would
have a 500 record for their first year
in las vegas with the raiders i'm ron
futura reporting
eight sports now